Tristan Thompson having a night out with
what could be a special someone and all
the while his drama with ex Chloe played
out on the Kardashians
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else yeah the NBA stars
cheating and paternity Scandal kick off
the show's second season he found out
July 2nd so he did know and since the
reality series new release Tristan's
seemingly unfazed new photos show the
Bulls player leaving the nice guy a West
Hollywood nightclub and while making his
exit he snapped leaving with only fans
model Juanita JVC yeah back there that's
Juanita and The Man Behind the iPhone is
Tristan I mean it's supposed to be a
really exciting amazing time and it's
just
a different experience I think this
comes after Tristan was spotted in July
with a mystery woman during a getaway to
Greece you can turn your life around you
can go through hell and high water but
you can still come out and fast forward
to August Tristan and Chloe welcomed
their second child via surrogate
ever since December it's been this Dark
Cloud looming over me every single day
I've been feeling depressed and sad and
now that my son is here I get to move on
and I get to enjoy
almost like I get to close that chapter
and be done with this trauma and put it
behind me and despite the never-ending
drama she didn't stop him from seeing
their little one
what about Tristan I don't know but I
don't he's not going to be in the
delivery room if he is going to be there
he'll be in the other room yeah but I
don't know my advice would be for the
sake of the baby I think if it's an
option
you did it once
mad at Tristan same situation
fish you can do it again and have him
there he'll have that story for your
child Coco prioritizing family tracks
with what E.T learned following the
fam's new addition A source told us at
the time Chloe is so grateful to have
been able to expand her family it's a
beautiful thing and Tristan really
wanted a baby boy and is so happy to
have welcomed a son hi tutu hi
do you want to see someone yeah who do
you want to see
[Music]
his name is not snowy
as for big sis true The Insider added
she is loving every moment about being a
big sister and wants to be a mini Mommy
to the baby
[Music]